parole pour le groupe l'est républicain
est à monsieur hervé mariton monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez dénoncé
vendredi les dégâts considérables
résultant d'augmentation d'impôts que
vous avez décidé depuis le début de ce
quinquennat il est vrai jean marc
ayrault avait annoncé aux français que
neuf sur dix seraient épargnés la
réalité est que tous les français ont
payé davantage
alors monsieur premier ministre
aujourd'hui et demain en 2016
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques en général
aimable à l'égard des idées socialistes
le fc ne nous indique que les éléments
obligatoires sur les ménages seraient au
taux le plus élevé de l'histoire de
notre pays plus de 28,2 pour cent de la
richesse nationale
c'est en effet que les ménages ont payé
en 2014 10 milliards de plus d'impôts 5
milliards de plus en 2015 payeront près
de 4 milliards de plus en 2016
vous avez beaucoup taxer les familles et
vous abusez du prétexte de la fiscalité
écologique les consommateurs
d'électricité auront payé plus de 5
milliards en quatre ans vous prévoyez
d'augmenter la fiscalité du gazole et de
l'essence de plus de 10 centimes par
litre d'ici 2020 le diesel que vous
dénoncez a bon dos le monde rural
souffre les abonnés au gaz paye en fait
toute la fiscalité de l'énergie
augmentent
ce sont tous les français qui payent
l'écologie mérite mieux que d'être le
camouflage de votre politique
d'augmentation d'impôts en 2016 la
potion est amère on le sait elle sera
aggravée par le collectif budgétaire de
décembre
alors pour 2010 est le seul pré ministre
année électorale
oserez vous renouveler l'engagement de
françois hollande qui nous avait dit
l'an dernier qu'en 2015
aucun français ne paieraient davantage
le président de la république a menti
pour 2017
monsieur le préfet ministre qui vous
croira merci monsieur marie toro
monsieur communiste
c'est le président monsieur le député
monsieur mariton s'est pas mais à culpa
qu'il faut c'est de la vérité et à
l'occasion de mon discours de politique
générale en avril 2014
j'avais pointé les mots depuis déjà un
certain nombre d'années qui concerne la
france chômage de masse déficits trop
élevés et fiscalité trop élevée
j'ai évoqué vendredi le poids de la
fiscalité sur les entreprises sur les
ménages fiscalité de l'état fiscalité
des collectivités locales vérité donc
vérité et choix qui ont été faits en
2012 puisque le déficit dépasser les 5%
puisque vous nous avez laissé 600
milliards de dettes alors il faut
toujours rappeler les chiffres monsieur
mariton et ces chiffres ils parlent
d'eux mêmes willy à une augmentation de
plus de 20 milliards entre 2012 entre
2010 et 2012 est tout autant
depuis 2012 on pourrait rentrer dans le
détail et savoir qui a été véritablement
imposé mais il ya eu cet effort de
redressement qui a pesé sur les français
qui a été demandée pour faire face aux
déficits et à l'endettement
je veux rappeler que pour les seules
entreprises la majorité précédente à
augmenter la fiscalité de 16 milliards
entre 2012 et 2014
la majorité actuelle de 18 milliards et
nous sommes grâce au pacte de
responsabilité
un train de baisser les charges et la
fiscalité de 36 milliards
c'est le cas encore avec le vote de la
loi de finances est vérité aussi pour ce
qui concerne la fiscalité qui pèse sur
les ménages puisque 12 millions de
foyers fiscaux vont bénéficier sur ses
deux années de la baisse de la fiscalité
vérité donc et monsieur mariton ce que
je vous demande moi aussi c'est être au
clair sur ce qui a été fait auparavant
et qui nous a amenés à redresser
le public dans les conditions que je
viens de rappeler et vérité par rapport
aux français pour le futur
comment allez vous faire pour financer à
la fois des priorités sécurité défense
et emplois tout en voulant baisser les
dépenses publiques de plus de 100
milliards comme tous les candidats de
votre parti à la primaire le propose
sans baisser les impôts c'est vous qui
mentent et aux français merci monsieur
le premier ministre pour le groupe
socialiste républicain